welcome to this video playing the M
Ziggler from norway norway right yeah
and then Zach Kings Indian our groom
thought the Kings again let's play the
same ish i played lots of this age three
line there which is also interesting we
get them transposition to a modern
benoni i want to prevent h4 for at least
a move
22 are young problem
yeah I always like to play Bishop age 6
in this kinda position if possible but
then here with the early rook to e8 yeah
this is a strange move it's kind it's
just running into a 45 I don't know if
he's got does he have some okay I my
play the movers that are going to play
anyway I don't understand it at all I
mean f-for what else and what what i
doing now d 5 a 9 5 it's the typical
stuff maybe night h7 here yeah this may
be this one but I have 94 still okay so
um should I first take on g6 or play d6
first not sure yeah let's play this
first this allows on possible Bishop c4
yeah I'm always amazed that they play
super complicated positions instantly
like it is also easy and clear at this
position is completely unclear to me I
mean I really need some time to figure
it out and okay so Bishop c4 is covered
hmm probably don't have them direct win
or anything I probably cannot play
without that
yes sure if it takes this III m maybe I
I was thinking about night before anyway
94 94 25 check I doesnt sit doesn't win
KX III mmm yeah he's attacking the
bishop from the side
k
so it's the top floor take very direct
measures here 26 9594 these are the
ideas it's all based on the fact that
the queen is offside
95 it's not to win I don't think he can
take Queen g6 is a win but maybe queen
or maybe Bishop g7 first but Queen g6 is
a tempo in the night h5 it is a
dangerous attack this is clear but the
term is it objectively strong I don't
know really
him
hmm
maybe had this oversight maybe really
bishop ever should be six I can take him
or with this one yeah it is dangerous no
doubt
let's see what movie explain how to
calculate really hard to tell okay this
is some move that I didn't expect at all
but it's a maybe not bad it's not some
night 95 194 maybe just night inform
gypsy for would be nice somehow i do
this I'm shop g7 but I can take edge for
a taxi three Wow take here vision 37 mm
with the temple that's
okay let's let's play that not lose on
time
queen bee to this rook everyone this is
some thread anyway
95 queen bee too I don't know we should
be seven or something if you place this
what am I what is my reply we oh that's
a greedy mouth I need to use this I
think look at five look at five and
twenty six look 5 may be queen bee too I
would have wished for a Bishop c4 I me
I don't want to exchange Queens with a
spread King position check
check
it's not even a check check check
check I know it's a syndrome oh come on
I'm morning how unfair is that check I
mean uh huh check oh this is this is
heartbreaking check after all this check
check check it's no game drawn ah oh the
shirts I mean Oh after this this game on
know when Drew Carey is its mm-hmm check
check yeah this is the drawl I'm just an
idiot I mean everything winds of course
everything Queen g2 everything check I
had no check no check whatsoever I come
on I need a break I just need a break of
course it was it was completely unclear
here I mean I thought that this was just
bad for black but this was probably
maybe talk to mr. you know it wasn't the
computer is just on plus 3 here okay so
f takes 26 let's look at the win here d
6 is not the win oops and 95 is just a
stupid move right okay so this is the
wind takes Bishop takes okay this is
very easy Knight takes Knight g5 and
[ __ ] twins yeah just g 6 + f6 hang yeah
all the black resigns this would have
been somewhat easier so it didn't work
out that way and okay around here yeah
this was a bad move or probably because
of age form and this now is just just
yeah computer says it's lost for white
with Bishop g7 and this now night d 5
wins okay but it said stuff oh here
night g 5 wins yeah very very clean win
and over rock f1 is the big point so it
continued like that this is winning
again and yeah just like that and this
is just just just gone and the only way
to do not win it was demonstrated in the
game okay thanks for watching